working for the U.S. government, so I have no conflicts. All right. So I think numbers of you
may have seen the manuscript we published several years ago in the New England Journal
using the VIPER regimen. And the rationale for that comes from a little bit of what I went over
yesterday, that we were really addressing BCR signaling, which is a major driving pathway,
particularly for the non-germinal center type of large cell. And this is showing the
pathway there. And the idea here was that in order to cure people, you needed to hit this
pathway at multiple points. And in fact, we hit BCR-1.
BCR signaling specifically using multiple drugs, prednisone, it turns out, through studies we did,
also inhibits BCR signaling. Ibrutinib inhibits ibrutin tyrosine kinase. And then down at the
very end, len also inhibits activation of NF-kappa B. And we combined that with BCR signaling,
doing this through inhibiting BCR-2 and abinituzumab. I just received from one of my colleagues a six-year
follow-up of the VIPER study, and the results are the same as what we published two years ago.
Time to treatment failure for all cases is 37%. These were all heavily pretreated large cell
patients. And for the patients who were not treated, the time to treatment failure for all cases is
37%. And for the patients who achieved CR, the PFS is still 78%. So we asked whether or not we could
improve on these. And so the data from the Polaroid study seemed to show that polatuzumab
added to RCHOP. And so we did a second study of adding polatuzumab. And that, as you saw,
is a very good study. And so we did a second study of adding polatuzumab. And that, as you saw,
targets CD79B, and the toxin is MMAE. So I'm going to give you unpublished data on what those results
are. So the way we did this is the VIPER part of this was the same. The only difference between
VIPER and VIPER-POLA is, as you can see at the very first drug, that we gave polatuzumab. And
we gave polatuzumab on day one of each cycle. This is fixed therapy. We do not do any maintenance.
And we now, actually, this is a little bit older data. At this point, we had 47 patients in,
median age 55. Most of these were DLBCL NLS, meaning they were ABC, Germinal Center,
Classified. And 23% were double-hit BCL2, stage 3 to 4 disease, 83%. And IPI 3 or higher was 57%.
These patients were relatively heavily pretreated, but not quite as high as what we did on our first
study. The first study we published was a median of three. In this case, it was a median of three.
But as you can see here, like the first study, 40% of these patients had received and did not
achieve a durable CR with CAR-T. And per Scholar 1, 53% were refractory.
This is very briefly giving you the breakdown here. You can see that most of these cases were
ABC, 47%. And we did not achieve a durable CR with CAR-T. And per Scholar 1, 53% were refractory.
11%, 15% were unclassified, and 38% were Germinal Center. The Germinal Center EZB cases were only
double-hit. And we did not put Germinal Center non-double-hit in this because our
original VIPER study showed that VIPER did not cure those people.
One thing we found here was that POLA essentially added no additional
toxicity to this. And I want to highlight that even though these are heavily pre-treated patients,
there was only 2% incidence of fever neutropenia. And those of you who treat relapsed large cell
know that with chemotherapy, that rate can go as high as 30%. So very well-tolerated therapy.
This is just showing you the waterfall plot.
Of them, you can see that the non-Germinal Center groups, most of those patients achieved CR.
And you can also see a relatively high CR rate within the double-hit BCL-2 group.
This is actually giving you kind of the overall picture here for all cases into this study.
58% achieved CR and 22% achieved PR with an overall
response rate of 80%. When we move over to the ABC group, the CR rate was 75% and the overall response
rate was 94%. And the unclassified was similar to the overall group. So this is actually, I'm going
to go through a number of Kaplan and Meyer curves. You can see here that with a medial response rate,
we're going to have a medium follow-up of over two years. We are now seeing a plateau at 40% for the
PFS curve. And when we look at it by ABC unclassified or Germinal Center, again, the
Germinal Centers were all double-hit. You can see that ABC for all comers was 70% PFS. If we also look
at all comers, we're going to see that ABC for all comers was 70% PFS. If we also look at all comers,
we're going to see that ABC for all comers was 70% PFS. If we also look at all comers, we're going to
see that ABC for all comers, we're going to see that ABC for all comers, but we look at it by line of
we're going to see that ABC for all comers, but we look at it by line of therapy, second line, it was
but we look at it by line of therapy, second line, it was about 78% PFS. We also looked at patients
therapy, second line, it was about 78% PFS. We also looked at patients that had failed CAR-T cells,
about 78% PFS. We also looked at patients that had failed CAR-T cells, and it was close to 40%. And
that had failed CAR-T cells, and it was close to 40%. And this is actually breaking it down by the
and it was close to 40%. And this is actually breaking it down by the lymph gem, and I'm not going
this is actually breaking it down by the lymph gem, and I'm not going to go through this, but you can
lymph gem, and I'm not going to go through this, but you can see BN2 and EZB MYC-positive were the
to go through this, but you can see BN2 and EZB MYC-positive were the lowest here. We also use
see BN2 and EZB MYC-positive were the lowest here. We also use Clonacy to look at MRD by CT, CT DNA,
lowest here. We also use Clonacy to look at MRD by CT, CT DNA, and by end of treatment, 66% of
Clonacy to look at MRD by CT, CT DNA, and by end of treatment, 66% of patients had become MRD
and by end of treatment, 66% of patients had become MRD negative. And if we look at it within the
patients had become MRD negative. And if we look at it within the CR by PET scans, 100% of these
negative. And if we look at it within the CR by PET scans, 100% of these patients became MRD negative.
CR by PET scans, 100% of these patients became MRD negative. And this is also looking at PFS by
patients became MRD negative. And this is also looking at PFS by whether or not their CT DNA was
And this is also looking at PFS by whether or not their CT DNA was greater than or lower than the
whether or not their CT DNA was greater than or lower than the median, and like ASH has shown
greater than or lower than the median, and like ASH has shown before, patients that had lower,
median, and like ASH has shown before, patients that had lower, that were below the median had a
before, patients that had lower, that were below the median had a better outcome. We also looked at
that were below the median had a better outcome. We also looked at what the outcome was in the
better outcome. We also looked at what the outcome was in the MRD status post, a single cycle, and
what the outcome was in the MRD status post, a single cycle, and you can see that patients that
MRD status post, a single cycle, and you can see that patients that achieved MRD by cycle one had a
you can see that patients that achieved MRD by cycle one had a 80% PFS. And if we look at MRD at
achieved MRD by cycle one had a 80% PFS. And if we look at MRD at the end of treatment, it was about
80% PFS. And if we look at MRD at the end of treatment, it was about 65%, and the cycle one MRD
the end of treatment, it was about 65%, and the cycle one MRD may reflect either lower CT DNA tumor
65%, and the cycle one MRD may reflect either lower CT DNA tumor burden or higher sensitivity to the
may reflect either lower CT DNA tumor burden or higher sensitivity to the cancer therapy, probably a
burden or higher sensitivity to the cancer therapy, probably a combination of both. And so I want to
cancer therapy, probably a combination of both. And so I want to thank Chris Malani, who has been
combination of both. And so I want to thank Chris Malani, who has been the PI on the study from the
thank Chris Malani, who has been the PI on the study from the very start, and also, of course, my
the PI on the study from the very start, and also, of course, my close collaborator, Lou Stout, and
very start, and also, of course, my close collaborator, Lou Stout, and all of the clinical teams.
close collaborator, Lou Stout, and all of the clinical teams. Thank you very much.